that's one thing would really get to me  like I'm not this type of person and the  truth is like you're not any type of  person you're not a stickman who just  like stays there you can be more and  also you should choose to be more  because you're not a static thing and a  phrase that massively infuriates me is  well that's just the way I am what the  way you are is due to a bunch of past  experiences you've had so if you think  about the future you being a combination  of the past experiences that you have  then it's every experience that you've  had from now to the Future you will be  the past so you might as well do it I'm  thinking about two or three people now  where I'm like you could be whatever you  want to be but you think you're just a  fixed type of person and so because of  that you're not going to be that person  and every time I see that person a part  of me just goes man I don't know how to  get this into you but man you could be  brilliant  [Music]